all right mother nature needs she owes
us an apology for not giving us more
rainfall with this system
but we all knew that it was going to be
cold it's beautiful out there i want to
show you
i see a little bit of snow on mount
potency up here
there's beautiful snow up in our
mountains we got four to six inches
and it's cold up there look at kyle
canyon it's 15 degrees
and we knew we'd be in the 30s this
morning i hope you've got the warm coats
and jackets ready to go
put away the umbrellas you don't need
those anymore we did get some rain in
some west and south valley neighborhoods
even a little hail in southern highlands
but we knew that the cold was going to
be what we really
really got a good dose of and we got a
lot of wind as well it's 31 in prompt 30
at red rock
and 40 up in mesquite 45 in laughlin
look where they got
amazing snow i happened to be up in reno
for the weekend visiting
my son at unr and it went from fall on
saturday
to this scene as i was leaving this is
from my
airplane seat oh my gosh it was
phenomenal snow they got
record snowfall up reno gardnerville
minden all those areas
up to a foot of snow almost six inches
in the reno area so they scored big time
up there
of course they're at 4 500 feet in reno
we got
a trace that's it a trace of measurable
not measurable rainfall but we didn't
get a trace so we still are at 203
days without measurable rainfall so we
got some good showers they showed up out
of the mountains
they popped across the valley there were
some neighborhoods west and south valley
that got
up to about 500 of an inch of rain so i
know you felt it you saw it a lot of
people were celebrating
the cold will continue to swing through
our area
stick around and it's really adjusted
our temperatures to
below seasonal norms we're looking at 56
today we should be
70. we won't get to that number this
week 59 and sunny tomorrow veterans day
mostly sunny and low 60s upper 60s by
the end of the week and that's pretty
much where we settle
into the weekend these mornings are
going to stay cold y'all we're talking
low 40s
and upper 30s so stay warm 6